في السودان اتفاق يتقدم بنسبه تفاهم مرضيه
لاطراف ازمه انتقال السلطه والتوقعات ان
تكون هناك اخيرا حكومه مدنيه قبل نهايه
شهر رمضان اربع نقاط حاسمه في التفاهمات
ابرزها الوصول الى توافق حول مبادئ
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري اجتماعات الناسات
تتكثف في الاسبوع المقبل حول القضيتين
المتبقيتين العداله الانتقاليه والامن
العسكري غير ان عقدتين كامنتين تسيران
بمستقبل البلاد نحو الغموض الاولى تحكمها
بقايا النظام السابق
مشاكل الثاني لمواجهنا برضو تغذيه الصراع
بين الاجهزه العسكريه في السودان
وحنذكر اسم عديل مجموعه علي كرتي تحديدا
مجموعه
تغذي الصراع بين الاجهزه العسكريه وتشغل
في الناس لانها هي تحاول تستعد لمحاوله
خلق الفوضى داخل الدوله السودانيه
والثانيه خلاف المكون العسكري الذي يتخوف
السودانيون من ان يتحول الى مواجهه انبرت
بها الصدفه واقعه العاب ناريه غطت سماء
وسط الخرطوم قبل اسبوعين وكانت كفيله برفع
درجه تاهب بين قوات الدعم السريع لكن هل
يمكن القول ان المكون المدني موحد هناك
اصطفاف بين مجلس المجلس المركزي وحلفائه
الموقعين على الاتفاق هو اخرى ترى انها
يجب ان توجد ككتله ترفض الاتفاق الايطالي
بالشكل الحالي هذه القوه في تشكيلها
معظمها من النظام السابق والحركات المسلحه
لا تمثل الثقل السياسيه الكبير وبعضها
لولا اتفاقيه سلام جوبا ما كان لها اثر
ما تم الاتفاق عليه بالامس ومن ثم دعا
لاجتماع
عاجل للمجلس المركزي
للحريه والتغيير ولذلك انه
اهميه الاجتماع الامس ايضا بتكمن في انه
لاول مره تم اتفاق على المبادئ والاسس
للاصلاح الامني والعسكري
وداء مضاف لما تم في الاتفاق الايطالي من
الاتفاق على الجيش الواحد وعلى الاصلاح
وعلى الدم
والاجتماع الامس كان اجتماع التميز بروح
وطنيه عاليه
من المكونه العسكري ومن المدنيين
والتطابقه الاراده بين المدنيين
والعسكريين في اجتماع الامس